la solution à ce problème est incroyable
imaginez c'est à vous de jouer avec les
BL dans cette position vous avez une
dame de plus mais votre ro est sur le
pont de se faire mater par le duo tour
cavalier adverse à première vue ça a
l'air imparable pourtant il existe un
sauvetage miraculeux si vousz chercher
par vous-même je vous laisse mettre
pause sinon voici mon raisonnement
d'abord j'ai cherché les échecs les
sacrifices je me suis vite rendu compte
que ça menait nulle part j'ai donc
ensuite constaté que mon roi était
coincé et je me suis dit si j'arrive à
donner toutes mes pièces restantes
peut-être je peux obtenir un Pat
miraculeux reste encore à comprendre
comment les donner et dans quel ordre
alors la solution c'est cavalier G1 on
vient bloquer la colonne la tour doit
manger le cavalier sinon avec les Blancs
on va mat en premier derrière on
sacrifie notre fou de la même façon tour
prend on vient donner notre tour tour
prend là faut pas se tromper on met la
dame en G7 pour attirer le roi et
derrière offrir notre dernier petit pion
qu'il recule ou qu'il mange ça fait donc
un Pat incroyable dites-moi si vous avez
trouvé la solution en commentaire ou si
vous aviez d'autres idées